so he has a guy such this one word to  describe nick Young Iggy Azalea getting  bombarded with questions about nick  Young after landing at LAX airport in LA  on Thursday but the 26 year old rapper  had a sense of humor about the baby mama  drama surrounding her ex-fiance plenty  of fish in the sea Iggy what's what's  right what's next someone without a cent  she's seemingly referencing the boards  that Nick is expecting a second child  with the mother of his four-year-old son  I gettin any now probs but you won't be  one like what things have gotten messy  since Iggy split from Nick last month  she accused the NBA player of cheating  and she's been vocal about how hurt she  is on Twitter what I feel like my body  was just drop kicked out of a plane with  no parachute I love you so much and now  much attached